sí muy buenas tardes para ti desde muy
temprano en horas de la mañana
específicamente las 11 de la mañana se
sentaron frente a frente y guillermo
lasso y yakubu pérez acompañados por una
comisión de observadores de la oea y los
consejeros del órgano comicial están
frente a frente a una sala pero el
argumento básicamente d iacu pérez se ha
extendido ha pedido la suspensión total
del proceso electoral hasta que se
recuenten todos los votos en las 24
provincias del país esta ha sido una
petición superior a la que venía
realizando que él pedía un reconteo voto
a voto en las siete principales
provincias donde han existido acta con
consistencia de igual forma el candidato
guillermo lazo ha dicho que él es el
primer interesado pero en el marco de la
legalidad para poder seguir adelante con
esta petición continúa realizándose en
la reunión entre los dos candidatos y el
consejo nacional electoral pero la
petición de los consejeros del órgano
comicial ha sido que salga a la prensa
fuera de las salas porque ahí se iba a
debatir acuerdos que
necesitaban la intimidad de los
candidatos junto al órgano electoral
esto ha generado disputas y diferencias
en contra del consejo nacional electoral
porque ellos piden que esté la prensa
dentro de la sala por el momento se ha
suspendido esta reunión se espera que el
día de hoy debería inclusive llevar esta
decisión a pleno esto debe estar
aprobada por el consejo nacional
electoral que en principio expresaron
que habría que revisar el informe
técnico para ver si esto era viable o no
para realizar el conteo todo sucede
cuando ya guillermo lasso que tiene un
conteo superior a 1974 por ciento de los
votos y ya que pérez el 19 38% de los
votos